alirio gracias a usted y el fiscal
general de la corte de karim khan a
aseguró que colombia está a la altura de
sus obligaciones internacionales está
usted de acuerdo con esa afirmación
bueno las víctimas en colombia ven con
preocupación esta decisión porque se
siguen cometiendo hoy en colombia'
crímenes de la competencia de la corte
penal internacional
durante el gobierno de duke
recrudecido la expansión del
paramilitarismo es uno de los temas que
observa la corte penal internacional
este año van más de 81 masacres en
colombia más de 130 líderes y lideresas
asesinados en el país entonces creemos
que era pertinente mantener la
observación internacional sobre colombia
si bien es cierto el presidente se
compromete a no entrometerse en la
justicia a darle recursos a la justicia
a garantizar la seguridad de los jueces
y fiscales pues este gobierno se ha
caracterizado por una autoritarismo por
atacar a las cortes por atacar a la
justicia especial de paz y
paradójicamente pues lo que dice la
corte penal internacional es que la
justicia está actuando y que la justicia
especial de paz está funcionando y creo
que es una decisión bastante polémica
las víctimas en colombia siguen
esperando que o bien la justicia
ordinaria o bien la justicia
transicional le dé respuesta y le dé
justicia a todos estos crímenes que se
han cometido durante muchos años y que
se siguen cometiendo hoy en colombia es
importante señalar que los crímenes que
están tipificados en el estatuto del
romá no son hechos del pasado son existe
se siguen cometiendo hoy en colombia
precisamente en la interpretación del
gobierno es que fue un voto de confianza
de la cpi esta decisión pero colombia
como usted bien decía atraviesa su
periodo más violento desde los acuerdos
de paz del 2016 esta es una noticia
desalentadora cuando más vulnerables
están las comunidades con constantes
asesinatos de líderes y lideresas
sociales como usted lo señaló masacres
cada vez más frecuentes principalmente
en zonas rurales
bueno digamos que el acuerdo tiene
algunos aspectos que nosotros rescatamos
es decir se mantiene el principio de la
complementariedad de la corte penal
internacional la corte mantiene
competencia sobre lo que están
sucediendo en colombia se mantiene el
escrutinio internacional el estado
colombiano y el gobierno tienen que
presentar informes periódicos sobre los
avances de las investigaciones en
colombia' los graves crímenes el fiscal
va a estar visitando cada año al país
para seguir monitoreando yo creo que lo
que hay que darle hoy es un respaldo
tanto a la justicia ordinaria como a la
jec para que se garantice que las
víctimas obtengan verdad obtengan
justicia y para que sobre todo no se
repitan los crímenes el fiscal
karim khan cambió el criterio y
considera que los exámenes criminales no
deberían durar más de dos años este
llevaba 17 años
precisamente porque en colombia la
situación de derechos humanos no mejora
como se quisiera y precisamente porque
este gobierno incumple la implementación
de los acuerdos de paz y de alguna
manera pues rompió las negociaciones con
el nn y no ha permitido que avance un
proceso de desmonte los grupos
paramilitares en colombia